[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american comedy film
called opposite day
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie opens with an adult monkey
named rodriguez arriving at the
cuddledyne corporation a research and
development company that specializes in
developing devices and machines catering
to parents and their children rodriguez
is welcomed by cuddledyne's doctor
godfrey larabee and his assistant
dimitri who have built an experimental
machine called the demystifier which
they believe can help parents fluently
speak the baby language
they put rodriguez inside the machine
and connect him to a baby monkey they
are hoping to help rodriguez speak and
understand the baby monkey language
rodriguez undergoes demystification but
the experiment goes sideways and when
the monkey exits the machine he comes
out wearing a diaper acting like a baby
monkey the machine has turned the adult
monkey into a baby monkey dr godfrey
screams in frustration as he is supposed
to present the demystifier to his boss
the movie then cuts to a group of middle
schoolers including samuel benson
samuel's sister carla benson sue and
jasper playing in the playground on the
slide samuel complains to his friends
about how his parents keep grounding him
for the smallest things carla comes to
her parents defense and tells the other
children that sam got grounded because
he rubbed butter on the banister and
slid on it in his underwear in sam's
defense butter bannister underwear
sliding is an american pastime sam rolls
his eyes and calls his parents bossy who
make random rules every day to restrict
his freedom and fun carla responds that
if sam had his way their whole house
would be a mess but sam continues his
rant and calls his life unfair and
claims that he could take the place of
his parents and do what they do with
ease he says that when he will have kids
he will let them do whatever they want
to sam carla and other children are then
joined by a boy named chaz larabee who
is dr godfrey's son upon hearing their
conversation chaz says that he actually
loves his dad but he just wishes his dad
played with him more everyone's parents
arrive to pick them up and chas watches
his friends leave with their parents
chas waits for his father for an hour
before his father finally arrives to
pick him up chaz is upset but when his
father gives him his favorite caramel
corn he forgives him in a heartbeat chaz
is basic
meanwhile when sam and carla return home
they see their paternal grandparents
jack and martha on the porch and quickly
deduce that they must be going on a
vacation sam's dad robert attempts to
hug his son but sam tells him that he is
all grown up now and asks rob not to
embarrass him in front of others as sam
and carla get prepared to head to their
grandparents remote cabin their mother
denise learns that she has to stay back
due to a work emergency and rob decides
to stay with her sam and carla are upset
but jack promises the kids that they
will have so much fun it will come out
of their ears godfrey takes his son to
his office while sam and carla go to
their grandparents holiday home on the
way to the cabin sam tells carla that if
he was in charge he wouldn't ruin family
vacation for stupid work meanwhile at
cuddledyne godfrey introduces chaz to
dimitri's son alexia and goes to meet
his boss mr montgomery who is getting
increasingly impatient to see the
demystifier godfrey and dimitri show him
a bunch of garbage devices to stall him
from seeing the demystifier but
montgomery threatens to fire him should
he not show him the machine left with no
choice godfrey decides to show him the
incomplete machine elsewhere martha
notices a wishing star outside sam and
carla's room and tells them to make a
wish
after martha and jack leave sam wishes
for a ps5 but the star doesn't give a
damn so sam wishes that kids ruled the
world before going to bed back at the
cuddle dine godfrey asks his son to be
the test subject so he could show his
boss how the machine works chas is a bit
skeptical but godfrey assures him that
he would have never asked him to do it
if it wasn't safe chas initially agrees
but later changes his mind and calls out
his father for using his son as the
guinea pig for his experiments upset
chas trashes the machine and it begins
to malfunction the machine begins
releasing white mist that not only takes
over the cuddledyne headquarters but the
entire city too when the smoke settles
chas reunites with alexia and they
notice that all the adults are acting
like children worried chas checks
godfrey's computer and tries to figure
out what happened the computer reveals
that the demystifier had a complete
malfunction resulting in leakage the
leakage created a mist that has taken
over the entire city for a five mile
radius causing all family members to
switch identities parents taking on
their kids personalities and children
taking on their parents personalities
when sam and carla who didn't come in
contact with the mist return back to the
city with their grandparents they
quickly learned that the world has
turned upside down all adults are acting
like young children and children have
become important people of the world
kids are driving cars running for mayor
starting only fans accounts putting out
fires and policing the streets sam's
wish has come true and he becomes
extremely happy he takes a stroll around
this new world with a big smile on his
face meanwhile martha and jack get
apprehended by a police officer for
driving a car as a minor and almost
being run over by a child i.e a man
sam and carla follow them to the police
station where they meet their school
friend jasper who has assumed the role
of his cop father martha and jack are
presented before a judge the judge
berates them for operating a vehicle as
a minor running a stop sign and trying
to bribe an officer with girl scout
cookies the judge sentences them to 25
years in solitary confinement sam and
carla have no say in this and they are
dropped back to their home by officer
jasper when they enter their home they
see that the house has been turned
upside down just as they wonder who
trashed their entire home rob and denise
pop out from behind the mess acting like
children they call carla and sam their
mum and dad sam makes full use of the
opportunity and makes rob and denise
clean the entire home carla calls him
out for abusing his power but sam argues
that it is payback time and their
parents had it coming later sam and
carla make their parents bathe and brush
their teeth before tucking them into bed
however sam's fun doesn't last long as
the next day rob and denise wake up
early and force sam and carla to make
breakfast for them as the new kids have
breakfast someone shows up at the door
it is sue carla's friend whose mother
works with denise sue has taken over her
mother's job and is here to pick up
carla as she has to give a very
important presentation at work they are
getting late for work so sue helps her
pick her dress after going through all
of denise's wardrobe they finally select
a black dress before leaving carla
reminds her brother that they must fix
this mess as martha and rob are rotting
in jail however she couldn't be further
from the truth as they are actually
having a ball in prison after the
breakfast sam somehow manages to drive
rob and denise to school meanwhile chaz
is continuing research at cuddledyne and
trying to complete some of his father's
projects when godfrey keeps bothering
him chas drives him to school at work
carla's boss reynold hands her the
original copy of a print advertisement
for a moisturizer and asks her to make
20 copies of it for the presentation
carla has never operated a photocopy
machine before plus not even
professionals can handle these things so
she struggles to xerox the ad and ends
up photocopying her face and arm after
the photocopy runs out of ink and paper
carla accidentally puts the original
copy in a shredder mistaking it for a
photocopy machine when sue arrives and
forces her to hurry up carla grabs the
photocopies of her arm and heads to the
conference room with her the clients
love carla's dress and ask her to begin
the presentation carla distributes the
photocopies of her arm which looks like
someone's bottom to the people in the
conference room she tells them that it's
a baby's bottom and comes up with a
random slogan for the moisturizer smooth
as a baby's bottom surprisingly the
clients love the concept calling it
fresh
meanwhile the excitement of being an
adult soon wears off for sam as he fails
to find anyone to play with him he
realizes that being an adult is not fun
and vows to change the world back to its
original form at a local eatery he sees
chas on the news chas is inviting people
having trouble reaching the shelf or
fitting into their clothes to visit
cuddledyne chas is taking his role very
seriously and plans to use his father's
idea of an overnight delivery bird
express to carry the mist to put the
kids in charge everywhere from london
new york tel aviv paris to new delhi
anticipating some resistance chaz hires
ninjas as his elite bodyguards chas is
no longer basic sam learns about chas's
plans to establish child supremacy all
over the world when he overhears chas
talking to someone on the phone when he
comes to pick godfrey up from school sam
follows him to the cuddle hq with rob
and denise they gain entry into the hq
posing as tourists he admits rob and
denise into cuddledyne's daycare and
goes on a tour of the company at an
opportune time he splits from the other
tourists and looks for chas he
eventually finds him preparing to send
the mist from the demystifier to every
corner of the world just then the
security spots sam snooping around the
company and they start chasing him
however he manages to sneak out with rob
and denise after returning home sam
tells carla about chas's evil plans they
then hire a baby to babysit rob and
denise before heading to the police
station there they meet jasper and tell
him about chaz's plans meanwhile chaz
kidnaps rob and denise from their home
sam and carla head to cuddledyne hq with
officer jasper sam tells chaz that it is
over for him only to realize that jasper
is colluding with him chas then reveals
his plans to demystify sam and carla
chaz locks them inside the machine and
orders alexia to finish the
demystification process of the benson
family while he goes to release the
birds carrying the mist but before they
could be turned into adults rob breaks
free from captivity and saves sam and
carla they are surrounded by the guards
but the siblings take them down using
godfrey's boxing gloves when chas learns
about sam and carla he sends his ninjas
after them however the two swiftly take
them out sam eventually finds chaz but
the latter freezes him with godfrey's
remote meanwhile carla gains access to
the demystifier's control panel using
godfrey's help and malfunctions the
machine she then helps unfreeze her
brother when chas again proceeds to
freeze him sam tries to reason with him
he reminds chaz how much he loved his
father and how much his father loved him
carla tells him that there's so many
wonderful things that parents do for
their kids like tucking them in at night
preparing dinner showing them new things
teaching them right from wrong taking
care of them when they don't feel good
paddling their asses when they're bad
and giving them hugs and kisses sam
reminds chaz that they have their whole
lives to act like adults so they don't
need to rush growing up chaz realizes
that it really do be like that sometimes
and realizes his mistake and decides to
recall the birds and change the world
back to normal sam and carla are
grateful to get their parents back and
promise to never take them for granted
again sam embraces his father and he is
no longer embarrassed about it meanwhile
godfrey apologizes to chaz for
neglecting him and promises to make him
his number one priority the movie ends
as sammy and carla go on a family
vacation while their grandparents are
still arrested the moral of this movie
is that no matter what lessons we learn
we will always neglect the elderly
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching